meanwhile a texas sheriff is ordering
his deputies to step up their vigilance
on roads and highways near the border
after his calls for assistance from the
white house to combat the surge of
migrants go unanswered
bexar county sheriff javier zalazar
writing in a letter to president biden
last month quote i cannot just stand by
and let my fellow law enforcement
officers continue to lose faith in your
leadership and administration please
help us sheriff salazar joins us now
sheriff your assets are being shifted
elsewhere uh from the border and now you
got to be border agents too right
well we're con we're concentrating our
efforts on the highways uh you know not
i wouldn't call this border agents i
would i would we're continuing our law
enforcement mission but we are having to
concentrate a little bit more on the
highways because of what's going on down
south why assets being pushed elsewhere
well from what we've understood uh
they're pulling a lot of border patrol
assets down south to the border which is
understandable they're dealing with a
sea of humanity in that humanitarian
crisis and they're doing what they can
but with that being said it's leaving
the state vulnerable in other areas and
we're not just going to let that happen
as texas sheriffs what are you seeing
coming through that never used to come
through before or they never used this
volume
you know it's an everyday thing but we
are certainly going to be seeing more
drugs coming up north we're going to be
seeing uh more guns and and stolen
vehicles heading down south and so look
it's just up to us to step up and fill
that gap you're not talking about a
democrat or republican you just want
something effective from washington were
you surprised you didn't get any answer
from your letter
um well i mean look i know that the
president's administration is busy with
what's going on in afghanistan i know
they've got other things going on on a
worldwide scale i can't even imagine and
make no mistake about it i do support my
president uh but with that being said
that's why i feel uh that it's my place
to ask for more uh in talking to some
some sheriffs from down south at the
border uh republican and democrat they
feel
left behind they feel left out and so uh
i'm i'm actually flying down south uh
later this morning with dps to go get uh
get a look at it i'll probably be
meeting up with with one of the local
sheriffs down there joe frank martinez
uh to see what we can do to help sheriff
uh what about you mayor what about you
governor
well uh look the governor i can't say
that i agree with his with his policies
of locking up these a lot of these
undocumented immigrants in the state
prison because what's that doing is it's
causing a backlog in the prison system
which is in turn affecting my jail
population and right now my deputies are
already working a lot of overtime to
keep up with the jail population so it's
a domino effect and so that's why i say
uh border problems are bear county
problems by default and and we're gonna
do everything in our power to help yeah
just give them a hand uh sheriff is
doing everything he can with the staff
that he has but he's being overwhelmed
and it affects everyone not just border
states and that's the message sheriff
javier salazar thanks so much
thank you i appreciate it